three different drainage areas
contribute flow to their respective
sewers which then all lead to pipe 4
using the given information below find
the time of concentration that should be
used for the design of pipe 4 in
minutes over here we can see drainage
area one leading to pipe 1 area two
leading to pipe two and area three
leading to pipe three all of these pipes
then lead into pipe four down here we
can see the time of concentration for
each drainage area as well as the pipe
length and pipe velocity for the
corresponding pipes leading away from
each drainage area and our objective is
to find the time of
concentration used for pipe 4 so this
problem is very easy if you know what
the time of concentration is and if you
don't know what the time of
concentration is you can look on page
377 of the reference manual where it
defines it as the time required for the
runoff to travel from the hydraulically
most distant point of the Watershed to
the point of interest and it also even
notes that multiple watersheds may
require summation of times to determine
an overall time for the
system that actually doesn't apply to
this problem and would apply more if one
drained to two which then drained to a
pipe but what we do have to do here is
decide to sum up all of the times from
pipe area one to Pipe One area two to
pipe two Area 3 to pipe 3 and figure out
which of those is the longest as that
will be the time of
concentration to be used for the design
of pipe
4 so let's get to it um the total time
for each area
is going to
be the time of the drainage area plus
the time in the
sewer and that's all it's going to be so
let's start so
A1 draining to P1 we'll say
equals 15
minutes for the drainage area plus 400
ft
over
2 feet per
second and if
we then
divide also or shall I say
multiply by 1 minute over 60
seconds both of these units will end up
in minutes because feet over feet over
seconds bring seconds to the top seconds
and seconds here will cancel out to get
minutes so
doing the math for this one gives
us
18 33
minutes A2 to
P2
equals 20
min
plus 450 ft over
3 feet per second again let's convert
our seconds into
minutes and that will give us
22.5
minutes and then finally we have
A3 to P3 and that's going to give
us 25 minutes to drain out of the Basin
or rather that the longest time for the
entire Basin to
contribute
and 400 ft
again over this time is
4 feet per
second 1
minute over 60
seconds and that's going to give us
26.67 minutes now our closest answer
over here is going to be 27 the other
answers that came out are the other two
drainage areas um and finally just the
amount of time coming from the pipe for
pipe 3 so as long as you don't fall for
any of that and you recognize that the
time of concentration is the longest
time for this pipe among all of the
contributary areas and pipes that's
really all this question's testing you
on and that's all there is to solve this
problem